ONE TEAER BTLINANCE H
STUDTSNPERS.TEAING
AT TCHER IJOE.
HE JNS UTONIT.
AN FOROINI US.
BLES YOU FORTHIS
ALREADYEAD CISI.REVIS TE
IOINE --HIGOUBLI
SCOL A A TEACR.
RE SULD INSEHE
CLSROO WH M STEN.
IT SHODNDSTAN BE I T[IUDIB].
A TEACR.RE MT IM
COND, BIEVEHAT TRE
EAYS TO FIGITY HA.YO DON DANEHE
E KS ITHE MDLEF E
FIGH TO ISEEKOU DENDS.
IAVEOTHI AINSTHE UNN.BU I HE SEO
FOR PITICGA.TH'S M AND.
FLHATESPI MYATTLG
I JT WT TO MEY LIFOPL RIG NO
RELENT.
THEHOUG THE CLLE OF
RVEO MY STUNT A IAN
UCHHE LIV ANDAKE
DIFFENCE INHEIRLIS.
Tucr: LLOU ARE GNG
ME ME CR
TH FACT YOU CANR A YOU A
GHTI IT
HIGH THAN T RI.UNTSS NK
--HAT' INSRINGO THE RT
OFUS.
WHY DYOU INKT'SMPORNT
TOEACH THE INERSOATHER
>> I HADONE TEMOT
LENI FORORE AN A YE
TH T STUDTS.IAVE EN THE LITATNS
E CHALLGESHAT A ACHER
IT'SOT REAY EFCTIV
INT PERN TEACNG. DOING
I FLT'S NOT ALSO FR T T
RES.
E PARTSHOUL A ENING
ANVING
NO LK AT TS I THEWEEP
Y.
ERE E SCHLSITHOVID.
I HAV4 STUNTSNY
CLSROOMND IM NOTWARE OF
ANYONEAVIN COD.
AMOT ARE OF ACHE
VINGOVID IN MY HOOL
I TNK IS A MIXTUREF THE
ENSU SATY. CIN UP WAYSO
NAIBLEI INK THENION H TOTOOK
AT TS O ASCHOOL TO SOOL
SIS.
THISSFAIR TO E SDENT